uh we did a survey recently where 77
percent
of um of the the rural schools don't
have access to any smartphones
and 88 have don't have access to
computers so
it's a real in south africa it's still
very much
the divide between the very innovative
fast-paced fintech companies where you
know it's really
great things being done and then you've
got the other side where
we've got a real um lack of need for
innovation and technology
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with c-tech welcome
to 20 minute leaders today i am joined
by melissa slaymaker
country director for south africa women
in tech
melissa is a speaker moderator and
advocate for diversity and inclusion in
the workplace
and helps to empower women through
connecting them to various programs
events and opportunities created to give
access to investors
mentors networking quality education or
job opportunities
melissa slaymaker welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
from south africa hi michael yes i'm
very well thank you for
inviting me to join your show today i
feel honored and humbled
i always don't look at myself as a
leader because i work with so many
phenomenal
inspirational leaders around the globe
on a daily basis that
um if someone points me out as a leader
i'm like oh really okay
but thank you for having me thank you
very very much for taking time out of
your busy schedule to be here
and today we're going to talk about your
work with with women in tech i also want
to talk about your personal journey
and a little bit going back how how you
got there you're also an
advisory board member of the africa
chamber of digital commerce i'm excited
to hear
what that's about you've had a variety
of roles across a variety of
organizations
and today you're really concentrating
your efforts and i'm excited to
so to start hearing about your journey
and then talking a little bit more
broadly about women in tech but also
the africa tech ecosystem
thank you definitely so um a little bit
about myself i started
i guess my journey working in the
science space i studied a science degree
in south africa and i wanted to work in
a laboratory like i mentioned to you
previously
um you know wanted to solve the world's
problems by finding cures in the lab and
then when i actually
graduated started working in that
laboratory space i found that my passion
was really for people
i wanted to talk to everyone and i
wanted to
find out more i was very interested in
people so um i started venturing out
into different career fields and
um happened to started working in
recruitment in the in the uk
um where i discovered my passion for
technology and for really
loving all the the changes and the
innovation and the fast-paced
environments of recruitment within the
technology space
and when uh companies approached us to
to help them find you know diverse teams
and help them find more women because
the tech teams were all men um which i
think
still today you find that a lot um i
found this challenge to be something i
almost took on personally
um as there was not enough women in our
fields in the you know coming into this
into the statement it feels
so it's always it's been a passion of
mine from uh from about you know 15
years ago when i started you know
sourcing for these it leaders and
things like that so when i was in the uk
i had the opportunity to
um to actually meet cheryl sandberg in
london with one of her book tours
signing when she did the plan b book
and uh you know obviously she also um is
a ceo for the
uh lean in initiatives that you know
helps women to kind of support each
other and i thought that was great
so when i moved to south africa after
about 14 years in the uk when i moved
back to south africa
i started the women in tech chapter
because it kind of really
um inspired me to bring all of my
knowledge of the technology space
of wanting to help women um in
empowering more women
and um you know it's come through uh you
know through a long journey of actually
a lot of experiences along the way that
kind of led to this path which i now
believe is my purpose so is to is to
help uh
help people connect um so women in tech
for
you know people that might not know a
lot about it it's a registered
not-for-profit business
um it's a global organization we've got
over 60 000 members and growing
internationally and we've got about 25
chapters currently
um i'm the um chapter um
or country director for women in second
south africa
and we've got our own platform which
encourages women to
connect um to to find learnerships
mentorships
job opportunities um just networking
with people that all want to
you know further themselves in their
careers or find investments
so it's just a phenomenal group and
sisterhood that i've
kind of learned to know over the year
and a half of just being involved with
it
um in in locally so um
and i think more so what i've discovered
is that there's still this need and this
this gap of
gender diversity is growing actually so
there's still this need
for for people not just to talk about
you know the the need for diversity in
technology and stem and in the future
but actually to take action and to have
that impact and that is what this
organization has given me is the
opportunity to actually
have that impact um to use my passion
for people to connect people
and to to use my my passion for
technology to really find out where are
the opportunities can we share the
opportunities and so on
um and some of the programs just to give
you an idea of what we do is we
um we we donate devices to schools
we work with interns and graduates to
give them confidence building through
some of our this is me programs
we've got mentorship programs to teach
people how to be a mentor
we're affiliated with partners like ibm
sco
microsoft to give free education and
technology
access to to people and some of the
schools in india we've helped to raise
devices for
and recently in south africa we donated
some devices to a rural school all
giving accessibility
to to be where is needed the most really
so the future we believe is in
technology if we can uplift more women
through that
then we can uplift their families and
the society around them as well
so that's the women in tech sides
now give me a little bit of context as
to
being a country director and and your
experience within south africa
specifically
what what is the tech ecosystem like
from your perspective
and how does women in tech fit in to
to to whatever is happening over there
so in south africa even though we're not
a first world country i think we've got
a lot of potential there's fantastic
startups especially
um in cape town which is like our
silicon valley um
there's so there's so many
internationally uh
you know focus of companies that are
international standards
that are in south africa and i think
when i came to south africa i wanted to
give those companies a platform
to showcase their products and their um
their their talents you know on
international scale
um there is a huge device though and
when it comes to
um you know the poverty line we've got a
lot of
work to do especially in the rural areas
to give access to
um you know to everyone where especially
where covert had such a dramatic effect
on you know schooling so children go you
know were all saints home schools were
closed because of the covert um
epidemic and now they were expected to
do homeschooling but they had no
access to technology to continue their
homeschooling so
it was a real um you know dramatic you
know
impact on on especially on those um
society you know the society where we
did a survey recently where 77 percent
of um of the the rural schools don't
have access to any smartphones
and 88 have don't have access to
computers so
it's a real in south africa it's still a
very much um the divide between
the very innovative fast-paced fintech
companies where you know it's really
great things being done and then you've
got the other side where
we've got a real um lack of need for
innovation and technology so
it's it's almost like a big divide and
it's trying
women in tech you know through our
programs and through our initiatives and
partnerships
is trying to really upskill empower
those
that need it most to get you know and to
also to showcase the
fantastic products and things that are
coming from our country on an
international scale so
yeah i hope that answers your question
and so
you where where do you fit in into this
puzzle you know if you if you look at
you know this ecosystem from a bird's
eye view where does melissa fit in
you know in this intersection between
all these moving parts
so i am basically i am the country
director so i'm i've started the chapter
um i registered we registered the
business as a as a non-for-profit
and we wanted south africa chapter to be
you know as of all
south africans are very competitive we
want to be the best and we want to do
the most
so we've got a great team of supports
and
partners and sponsors that we work with
um so i'm not on my own i'm the you know
director and i manage it
from south african point of view um but
we've got a youth team
that focuses on some of the hackathons
and the youth products
um projects that we're doing um we've
got
a board of advisory
advisory board members that give advice
from a very strategically high level
a lot of corporate sponsors and partners
that we work with
so i'm not alone but in terms of just
managing it i'm just the person that
said hey
we should south africa should be on the
map of this global movement
um and you know if uh you know if
when i contacted the organization uh
ayumi
who's the ceo said that well there's no
south african chapter but why don't you
start one and
that just to me was like okay let's do
it you know so i think
for me it's always been if i see a need
for something
you you kind of put it into manageable
goals and you create it you do it
you know you don't wait for something to
you know be creative if
if if you see the need then um you know
just go for it
right can you share some some examples
of how
of how you know you work within the
ecosystem
to to either make an impact or to change
the way people think about something or
to encourage people to do something
so that's different everyone's different
right so everyone has different ways of
in different needs so i think it's
looking at the target audience who you
know who you're trying to approach
so if you're wanting to um speak to an
investment
company for instance it's getting them
to understand the need
and the benefits really of why they
should be investing
in women founded companies or women
startups um
because you show them you know you show
them the the results the studies the
service that's been done
and you know at the moment this you know
from mckinsey reports
only three percent of the
woman far of the funding going into um
the african space was a woman fine
founders so this is real gap for
you know for getting a diverse
investment coming into businesses that
our women founded or co-founded by women
so
we really want to for instance show
investors
um the benefits of investing in women
farming companies and research has also
shown
that the companies that are you know
diverse
are more profitable and their products
are more
diverse when it comes to their customer
experiences which also makes the company
get more retention on their on their on
their
the clients and the the customers that
they that they have
so it's making companies aware your
question was how do you change their
minds or how do you get them
to see the way that you're thinking is
really just by
showing them the proof showing them the
results speaking to them
about um you know the benefits
i think if you want to kind of sell an
idea to anyone is really
telling them why and how it's going to
be applicable to them
and what is the benefits going to be for
them what if it's commercial if it's
ethical if it's
you know um if i don't know if you've
seen a documentary recently on netflix
um called coded bias where they
actually showed a a you know an african
female woman coding a product for an ai
product that's
used as facial recognition but it didn't
recognize her face
because um you know they they were such
already biased within the coding which
is quite scary
so it's kind of like those documentaries
making people aware of the the dangers
of not having a diverse society and
future and
our future is being coded today so we
are busy with machine learning and
putting in the ai and the tools
necessary
that we're going that's going to shape
our future and
showing companies the benefit of having
that future being
a diverse one which is a no-brainer but
you know some
some people are still not aware of this
and it's it's just creating that
constant
um awareness and then being able to
to use my network which is women intake
with this
africa chamber of digital commerce or
whether it's you know my day
day job of recruitment to keep sending
that message just out
and to let people you know see the
benefits
tell me a little bit about the the
africa chamber of digital commerce
and what is that nonprofit and and your
role as an advisory board there but
but what what is this what is the sort
of the aim of this organization and how
does it actually go about
achieving that so the african chamber of
digital commerce
is uh basically uh like you mentioned a
non-for-profit it's
based in minnesota in the us and um it
was started by
the ceo eric kaigama who
basically wanted to um take use the
africa diaspora
so those uh you know people who are from
an african descendants who's maybe been
abroad
um in in the states or in the uk
wherever it will be considered first of
all
and then returning back to africa with
their skills and with their knowledge
that they've maybe have
learned from overseas and to bring it
back and so that's
um we you know but looking at it from a
kind of digital space as to saying how
can we create more jobs in africa
um how can we especially when you're
looking at remote jobs so
you know through again through the
kermit pandemic and there's been
um this real acceleration towards
um digitization and you know
people being able to um get remote jobs
and working
you know from anywhere um especially if
you're getting paid you know
living in africa now you can have the
opportunity to get paid in usd
or in pounds or in euro it's obviously
very attractive for them
but still we have a lack of this
infrastructure problem
so how again similar to women in tech
how do we get the infrastructure
there for them to have access to the
internet to have a safe environment
where
they can go and do their remote work
you know a lot of these countries are
still struggling with the basic
infrastructure
some of them still struggling with the
basic needs of water
you know so in zambia a woman in chapter
there
her first project was to get water to
the village
then it was um you know get the
infrastructure safe space for the
children to go
then it's okay let's get solar power to
get some
electricity then it's okay let's get
devices
you know so the problems are are much
different on the african continent
so with the african chamber of digital
commerce is getting together special
projects
to help more rural areas um to get
access to the infrastructure
so that they can get access to the
digital world
and um get themselves out of poverty
through um technology so it's again i'm
an advisory board member there
because we wish to also get more women
included
in that digital transformation that's
you know going across the african
continent which is great
sounds uh it sounds amazing it sounds
like a you know
really really impactful one you know
dealing with some of the most important
problems that that are really
you know impacting people's lives and so
i i want to ask this question i think i
already understand the answer but i
would love to hear your
your real take on this you know you're
choosing to dedicate your your time
to to these non-profits and work there
uh
obviously you know in the tech ecosystem
you could be doing a lot of other things
that are that are for-profit
and that are very lucrative why you know
why dedicate
pretty much all of your time to this
right now so what what is it about you
know the day-to-day that you do that
really gets you going
so i just i was doing um i haven't
obviously have a day job should i stay
and then i volunteer a lot of my time so
you're all right and i'm the mother of
two
so it's it's just time management it's
really um
something sparked inside of me
throughout my career that just said
um i wanted to give back i wanted to
um i guess one of the things i think if
you speak to a lot of parents
um you want once you have children i
guess you you think you want to
have a legacy or you want to leave the
world a better place for your children
and um i for me i wanted to do something
and that was going to leave a legacy for
my children so they can go
oh what did your mother do or you know
oh and then you
you know they hopefully one day will be
proud of me so in that sense um that's
why i do it
it's so that i can think of well i've
you know
i've got two children that um will want
to
you know hopefully um leave the world in
a better place
you know for their children one day so
it's just leading by example
and that's the that's the reason why i'm
doing this
um but i do also obviously have a day
job so i do recruit soul
in the technology space and so i do
um yeah so i do love what i do and i can
they use the profit and not-for-profit
companies um
to you know work together very well so
some of our corporates that we recruit
for
we get them involved in some of the the
projects to donate to do donations for
some devices or
so there's a lot of um networking
opportunities that's
um you know that helps my day job as
well so
i think it's it's really i'm in a really
great uh
privileged place that i can do good
through my work
you know that i can work but also um
share
you know give back so yeah that's that's
why
very very cool melissa thank you so much
for joining me i i had a great time i
have three short
and fun questions for you uh before we
leave and i want to take you back to
your childhood what really fascinated
you as a kid what was
perhaps a subject in school or anything
that really fascinated you
oh so for me um it has always been
people
so i've always been really um you know
like one of those people at the airport
that would just people watch
and just i just find people so
interesting and
um just the difference in um you know
all the
all the differences culture or race or
religion or whatever just i just find
people just are really interesting
and i think um even as a kid i used to
always
be the the child that i never really
belonged to any group
in school like i was sporty but academic
and i was a nerd but i also did
you know so i was i was always just
friends with everybody
and um i just never really wanted to be
like um you know just a specific group
you know so i was always just
just friendly to everyone and talking to
everybody and um i think that's just
because that's how i am you know very
bubbly um
energetic and just kind of um just love
sort of sharing you know stories and
learning from other people
and a source of inspiration along your
journey
person real not real
oh um it's a difficult one there's so
many i also always like
if i can ask like who you know inspires
you i can think of
so many but um i read that recently on
one of the late
probably late comments of people that
read the becoming book by
michelle obama so i only recently got a
copy of it and i was just like wow this
is so
you know such a this is exactly um how i
hope that uh my life would also go is
that you never and
you never um stop at a certain period of
your of your life and think okay
i've made it you know i can sit back now
and
you know retire or whatever so you're
always you're always
learning you're always there's always
something you know the next
um the next chapter or the next hill the
next part of your journey so
i think that's and the some of the i
don't know if you've read that book but
definitely do
it's it's really it's um i like the fact
that
she really um talks very personally
about her experiences and
i do like autobiographies um and
learning from people so
i'm always reading um kind of what
you know other people have done in their
life journeys and learning through
through those
stories very very very cool
and three words that you would use to
describe yourself
three words to describe myself um i'd
probably say
very energetic um very
positive um
and i really care i really care so when
i
um when i speak to people i always try
and
um you know really engage
and uh and listen and try and see
you know understand from their story so
um i think
yeah that's it really wonderful melissa
thank you very very much this is
wonderful thank you for everything
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you for your time michael
appreciate it